ROGER MARTINEZ: There are
thousands of applications
that you can run on Google
Cloud Compute Engine, each
with different requirements.
To meet those
requirements, Google Cloud
offers VM families, each
optimized for specific needs.
I'm going to help
you make sense of it
by reviewing some important
factors to consider
when choosing the right
Compute Engine VM.
If you want to
choose the right VM,
first let's review how VMs
are organized in Google Cloud.
All VMs are categorized into
either general-purpose or
workload-optimized families.
General-purpose machines provide
the best price performance
ratio for a variety
of workloads.
As of right now, there
are three machine types
within the
general-purpose family.
Efficient machines
deliver reliable,
sustained performance, the
lowest total cost of ownership
of any VM in Google Cloud.
They're about 31%
cheaper than N1 machines.
Balanced machines offer
more customization
and a wider feature set.
And tau, which represents
torque in physics,
puts the pedal to the metal
for industry-leading price
performance.
Tau is recommended for
scale-out workloads,
such as web servers,
containerized microservices,
and media transcoding.
T2D is our first offering
in the Tau family
and provides full x86
compatibility on third-gen AMD
EPYC processors.
As you go through
the three types
of general-purpose machines,
efficient, balanced, and Tau,
they each have different
levels of price performance,
where efficient
achieves the best price,
balanced sits in between
providing the most feature
flexibility, and Tau has a
best price-performance ratio.
As for those
workload-optimized machines,
there are three
families here, too.
Compute optimized machines will
offer the highest consistent
performance per
core, ideal for users
with performance-intensive
workloads.
C2 VMs are built on architecture
that utilizes features
like non-uniform memory
access to achieve the highest
performance.
Memory-optimized
machines are best
suited for memory-intensive
applications,
providing the largest
ratio of compute
to memory and the lowest
cost per gigabyte of memory.
They provide the largest
SAP-certified machines
with up to 12
terabytes of storage.
And accelerator-optimized
machines--
they offer the highest
GPU performance
for those heavy
artificial-intelligence
machine-learning workloads.
Google Cloud is
the first platform
to be able to attach 16
A100 GPUs to a single VM,
allowing you mega performance
to scale up and out.
OK, that's how
they're organized,
but that won't help you choose
between a general-purpose
n2d-highcpu-64 and a memory
optimized m1-megamem-96
for instance.
These names don't exactly
roll off the tongue.
But understanding the naming
convention going on here
is a valuable step towards
making the right choice.
It's pretty simple.
The first part of the name
refers to the machine series.
This will tell you the
category of machine.
For example, n2 machines run
Intel, and n2d denotes AMD.
And both are categorized
as general-purpose.
Each series is available
as different machine types.
That's there in the middle.
Each type has a different
virtual-CPU-to-memory ratio
to fit different workload
requirements, like highmem,
highcpu, standard, et cetera.
Lastly, the name
ends the number,
which refers to the number of
virtual CPUs for that machine.
So now you can deduce
that an n2d-highcpu-64
has 64 virtual CPUs.
And as part of the
highcpu type, it
has one virtual
CPU to 1 gigabyte
of memory ratio in the
n2d series, which is
in the general-purpose family.
In contrast, the m1-megamem-96
has 96 virtual CPUs.
And we know it'll have a
higher ratio of memory,
because it's in the
memory-optimized family
of m1 machines, which is a
workload-optimized family.
At the end of the
day, the right VM
will largely be
based on what you're
going to use that virtual
machine for, and then
from there, figuring out
how much CPU and memory
you'll need.
This can help distinguish
the machine needed.
For example, AMD machines come
in larger configuration sizes.
Or, if you require
high memory value,
memory optimized
is the way to go.
If you're migrating
an application
from an on-prem system, we
recommend some benchmarking
and data collection to
understand the application
characteristics or testing the
application on the machine type
before deploying
it in production.
When choosing your CPU
and memory requirements,
you should also be
sure to pay attention
to the flip side, the CPU and
memory that you don't need.
That is, you should
be careful not
to over-provision your machine.
For example, a general
purpose n2-standard-2
will provide you with
two virtual CPUs and 8
gigabytes of memory.
But let's say the
application you're
going to run on
the instance uses
most of the CPU most
of the time but never
really uses more than about
2 gigabytes of memory.
Well, in that case,
you might be better off
on an n2-highcpu-2 instance.
That way, you're not getting
billed for 6 extra gigabytes
of memory that you don't need.
Making sure you're provisioning
just the right machine
for your needs ensures
that you're not
overpaying for resources
that you may never use.
If you're not sure, no worries.
Google Cloud provides
rightsizing recommendations
based on your usage data to
get the sizing just right.
These recommendations are
available within the Compute
Engine instances page or
within the Recommendations Hub.
If none of the available machine
types fit your requirements,
keep in mind, there's
always custom machine types.
With custom machine
types, you can
configure just the
right amount of CPU
and memory for your
particular needs.
In some cases, you could
expect to save 50% or more
compared to predefined types on
other public cloud providers.
With all things considered,
if you're still not
sure what machine
type to choose,
start off with something small.
You can always
move your workload
to a larger machine at any time.
Besides CPU and memory,
another performance metric
you should consider
is disk performance.
If your application
needs the best disk IOPS,
you're going to
want to make sure
that you choose an
instance type that
will be compatible
with one of two
high-performance
exclusions, local SSDs
and extreme persistent disks.
Local SSDs have the
advantage of being physically
attached to the server
that hosts your VM,
so you can get higher
throughput and lower latency
than standard persistent disks.
They offer local block storage
that is ephemeral and great
for processing space,
buffers, caches,
and other temporary data.
And for high-end,
performance-critical
applications, extreme
persistent disks
will offer higher maximum
IOPS and throughput
than other options.
But keep in mind,
they'll require
at least 64 virtual CPUs.
Beyond disks, there
are other features
that you may need to
check compatibility
for when choosing your VM.
There's confidential computing.
This is a service that
encrypts data in use
while it's being processed.
The transition to
confidential VMs is seamless.
All workloads we run today can
also run as confidential VMs--
no extra code changes to
applications, just one checkbox
to protect against
rootkit and boot kits.
But if you plan on using
confidential computing,
you'll have to choose an n2d
from the general-purpose family
of VMs or a c2d from the
compute-optimized family.
Another feature is sole tenancy.
This lets you have exclusive
access to a physical Compute
Engine server that's
dedicated to only
the VMs in your project.
This can be required
for licensing
of certain applications.
With any Compute
Engine feature, be
sure to check out the
documentation for VM
compatibility when you're
deciding on what VM to choose.
So now that we know how to
choose a VM, let's choose a VM.
Let's say that my only
requirement as of right
now is a virtual machine
with 16 virtual CPUs.
With only that requirement,
let's see what options I have.
The workload-optimized machines
could be a good starting point.
c2-standard-16 will give
me the CPU that I want.
It's a standard type, so it's
got standard CPU-memory ratio.
What about
general-purpose machines?
What do they have to offer?
We'll start with seeing
if e2's will be a fit.
Well, an e2-standard-16
has similar specifications,
16 virtual CPUs and
64 gigs of memory.
And it's priced a bit lower
than the workload-optimized c2.
We'll add that as
a possible choice,
noting that this would save
us some cost over time.
OK, now what if the
performance of our application
will need some block storage?
Local SSDs are an
excellent solution here.
According to the
documentation, we
can't attach a local SSD to
an e2, nor a t2d machine,
but we can attach one to a c2.
We still want a
general-purpose option.
That's not a problem.
There's n2-standard-16,
n2d-standard-16,
and the n1-standard-16.
All these
general-purpose machines
offer the same specifications
on different microarchitectures
and are compatible
with local SSDs.
All right.
Now, what if we did some
testing and found out
that while we
can't budge on CPU,
our application actually runs
pretty well with less memory?
This is our chance to
optimize our cost by choosing
a high-CPU machine type.
n2-highcpu-16, n2d-highcpu-16,
and n1-highcpu-16 all
have the same CPU as
the other options,
but with only 16
gigabytes of memory.
c2 machines are
highly performant,
so our application
will run great on one.
But we'll be spending more
on additional performance
and memory that won't be used.
So let's just remove
c2 from our list.
Based on our
requirements so far,
we've narrowed down our choice
to any of these three choices.
As more machine
families and series
are added to the
Compute Engine lineup,
your available
options might differ.
It's always a good idea to
check the latest documentation
when researching what
VM will work for you.
So what do you think?
What factors came into play
when you chose the right VM?
Let us know in the comments.
Until next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]